aux vingt ans la dernière fois que vous
êtes venu c'était pour la journée de la
femme ou souvenirs ça mais très bien
j'ai beaucoup parlé de sodomie plutôt
que de vos bouquins ce soir là et vous
disiez ou aux femmes de s'équiper de
gode ceinture pour montrer aux makes que
ça faisait vous souvenez de ça et je
vous ai trouvé ce soir là très proche
des femmes
nicolas si vous étiez une femme se fait
que toi votre prénom
qu'est ce féminin d'un roman romane a la
chance que vous avez moment je sais
c'est un pote j'ai vu comment vous la
regardiez tout à l'heure à votre coeur
et l'esprit la rigueur
richard moi quelqu'un parlait comme ça
de ma vie j'aurais bien pas moi c'est
une femme
est-ce que vous soyez une femme facile
une femme facile je serai je serai pas
une femme ultra difficile
vous seriez honnêtement vous seriez une
[ __ ] qua non non je crois une
[ __ ] voit l'art uniquement quand la
bougie et est un plus
est ce que vous tapez auriez nicholas
ray si vous étiez une femme non je un
type qui écrit des bouquins qui passe à
la télé c'est le faux plans non je me
taperais plutôt à un prof d'histoire géo
ou un jardinier fait un mec du concret
quoi c'est l'occasion inespérée en même
temps un tué sur l'étape assez souvent à
vous taper tout seul c'est souvent c'est
parce qu'il ya en même temps ça permet
d'être compétitif après ça si vous étiez
une femme est ce que vous feriez refaire
les seins si j'étais une femme je crois
que j'aurais des petits seins je sais
pas a continué sur les yeux tu commences
sauver les petits soins avec un petit
plus sec et nerveux et va pas ensemble
est en fait en fait en plein jeu
dans ces cas là moi en tant que femme je
refuse de vous savez comme ces porno des
années 80 avec les ongles hyper long et
les seins siliconés je préfèrerais
conserver des petits seins parce que ça
comme ça des petits seins quand on les
embrasse on est plus près du coeur alors
si une femme qu'est ce que vous voulez
pour être in de romane bohringer bouc
émissaire c'est lui qui s'est moqué
pendant un peu plus de discipline par
nicolas qu'est ce que vous feriez contre
les rides les ridules les pointes sèches
et les cheveux qu'elles sont un vrai
problème parce qu'il faut bien se marrer
croyez quoi il est riche c'est très beau
ça fait des éventails au coin des yeux
ça boit ça il sait parler aux mêmes
heures en un très bon et je dirais ça
c'est un truc que je vais ressortir
jamais je pense que tu commences à avoir
de sacrées éventail
c'est pas moi que je parle c'est au
feeling alors tiens nicolas vous étiez
une femme il ressemblera à quoi votre
mari
parmi tous les gens qui sont autour de
cette tâche quelle serait votre mari
voilà ça va être chaud bah c'est vrai à
boehringer quand même il est actif dans
l'émission qui juge à l'émission et
pourtant j'en ai vu
oui il y avait un mari oui je suis une
femme avec des petits 5 c'est vrai que
si j'ai un mari
il faut il faudrait qu'ils me fassent
pas chier quoi vous savez le type qui
moi un peu mais qui s'est forgé un an
mais non c'est pour ça plutôt la membres
âgés alors le mari parce que tu te la
renault espace la barre des patins dans
sa baraque de singles et en normandie
mais un amendement est ce que pour la
france
est-ce que vous choisiriez comme avant
vous oui uniquement dans un club
échangiste him
or
m
c'était l'été
comprennent messieurs dragon punch et au
diable vauvert
tout me collard